"
[ MUSIC ]
>> I THINK THAT WORDS WERE
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL.
HE SPOKE PERSONALLY ABOUT THE
MORAL OUTRAGE WHICH HE FELT,
WHICH IS SHARED BY PEOPLE ACROSS
THE WORLD.
IT DOES NOT MEAN HE IS
ARTICULATING A CHANGE IN POLICY.
IT IS NOT --
>> DOES HE REGRET THAT THOSE
WORDS OVERSHADOWED A LARGER
MESSAGE?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
HE SPOKE FROM THE HEART.
>> Greg: BRAND-NEW SPENT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE AS THEY TRIED TO
WALK BACK TO WIPE BACK -- WALKED
BACK.
APOLOGIES IF THAT SENTENCE MADE
YOUR BRAND WALK BACK.
THE WHITE HOUSE CLAIMING BIDEN
WAS SPEAKING IN HIS PERSONAL
CAPACITY ABOUT RUSSIA'S
PRESIDENT, EVEN THOUGH THEY SAID
HE WAS NOT SEVERAL TIMES.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT BIDEN
MEANT IS SO CONFUSING THAT JOKE
HAD TO USE NOTECARDS JUST TO GET
HIS STORY STRAIGHT BUT IT CAME
WITH THE HELPFUL LABELED IN CASE
HE GOT MIXED UP WITH OTHER
CARDS.
DON'T WORRY.
DON LEMON HAS THE WHITE HOUSE
COVERED.
>> I THINK THIS IS A
MANUFACTURED STORY.
I THINK WE SHOULD EASE OFF A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE THAT IS NOT
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID.
HE DID NOT SAVE REGIME CHANGE.
>> Greg: OKAY, IT IS ALL JUST
MANUFACTURED.
JESSE, THE PERSONAL CAPACITY
LINE.
>> Jesse: YEAH, 25th
AMENDMENT.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
TELEVISION.
>> CAMERAS.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THIS SEEMS MORE SERIOUS THIS
TIME.
LAST TIME, IT WAS TRIVIAL.
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO STOP PLAYING
"HILL TO THE CHEAP" BECAUSE HE
IS NOT PERFORMING THE DUTIES.
HAS ANYBODY SEEN THE RAW FOOTAGE
OF HIS SITDOWN LUNCH WITH THE
AMERICAN SOLDIERS -- SOLDIERS?
HE WALKS IN THAT ROOM AND
THERE'S NO ELECTRICITY.
HE STARTS TELLING A STORY ABOUT
THE LAST TIME HE WENT TO IRAQ.
AND HE SAID, HE WANTED TO HIDE
HIS NAME.
HE CHANGED IT TO HUNTER.
AND THE STORY NEVER LANDED AT
THE WHOLE PLACE WAS SOLID AND
THEN HE JUST SITS DOWN AND GETS
A PIECE OF PIZZA.
I REMEMBER SEEING THE FOOTAGE OF
BUSH AND TRUMPET YOU GO TO A
MESS HALL IN A WAR ZONE AND YOU
ARE SERVING THE FOOD.
THERE'S SELFIES EVERYWHERE AND
PEOPLE ARE JUICED UP.
DISPLAYS, YOU HAVE HEARD A PIN
DROP.
HE SHOVES A PIECE OF PIZZA IN
HIS MOUTH AND HE STARTS CHOKING.
THERE WAS A JALAPENO PEPPER ON
IT AND PEPPERONI AND HE STARTED
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING IT DOWN
AND THEY NOTICE AND THEY START
ASSISTING HIM AND THEY START
HANDING HIM A GLASS OF WATER AND
HE SITS ON THE WATER AND THEN HE
STARTS TAKING A NAPKIN AND ROLLS
UP THE NAPKIN AND HE STARTS
DABBING HIS FOREHEAD AND HE PUTS
IT DOWN.
NOW, IS THIS THE WAY YOU EXPECT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO ACT WITH OUR SOLDIERS?
A COUPLE MILES FROM A HOT WAR
WITH RUSSIA?
NO.
YOU EXPECT MORE FROM SOMEONE
LIKE THIS.
THE WHEELS ARE FALLING OFF.
THIS GUY IS LIKE A VINTAGE
CARDS.
YOU SEE THAT PAGES.
THE BRAKES ARC SHOP.
IT IS NO LONGER FUN TO DRIVE.
>> YOU KNOW WHY HE ATE THE LIKE
THAT?
IT IS BECAUSE HE IS IRISH.
NOW, BEING IRISH, I AM IRISH.
IT IS THE GO TO EXCUSE
APPARENTLY.
I THOUGHT THAT MOMENT WOULD BE
-- VERY TIMELY AS HE DOES
BRILLIANTLY.
ALL OF THE MUSIC BUSINESS AND
ALL THAT RIDICULOUS -- BIDEN
JUST SAID STRAIGHT.
NONE OF THAT HAPPENED.
>> DO YOU HAVE THAT TAPE?
>> NONE OF THAT HAPPENED.
HAVE WE GOT IT?
>> OTHER LEADERS IN THE WORLD
ARE GOING TO START TO DOUBT THAT
AMERICA IS BACK.
IF SOME OF THESE BIG THINGS THAT
YOU SAY ON THE WORLD STAGE KEEP
GETTING --
>> President Biden: PUTIN --
>> IT SOUNDED LIKE YOU TOLD U.S.
TROOPS THEY WERE GOING TO
UKRAINE.
IT'S HUNDRED LIKE YOU SAID IT
WAS POSSIBLE THE U.S. WOULD USE
A CHEMICAL WEAPON AND IT SOUNDED
LIKE YOU WERE CALLING FOR REGIME
CHANGE IN RUSSIA AND WE KNOW --
BY DEMETRIC NONE OF THE THREE
OCCURRED.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN CANNOT OF
THE 3-FOOT WE HEARD YOU SAY EACH
OF THOSE THINGS.
THEN WE READ THE LOCK NEXT IN
YOUR OWN PRESS OFFICE.
AND THEN WE SAW YOU WALKING
TRACK THE WALK BACKS AND NOW YOU
HAVE MOVED TO FULL DENIAL MODE
OR PERHAPS MORE SINISTER THEY,
YOU HAVE MOVED TO COMPLETELY
FORGETTING MODE.
HE GENUINELY DOES NOT REMEMBER
SAYING ANYTHING.
>> IT COULD HAVE BEEN THE HOT
PEPPER.
I WAS GOING TO SAY -- SQ ABOUT
HAVING YOUR MOST BASIC IDEAS ON
NOTECARDS.
I HAVE THAT WRITTEN DOWN AS A
QUESTION.
WHO AM I TO JUDGE, JUDGE?
>> I MEAN, EITHER HE DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND THE CONSEQUENCES OF
WHAT HE SAID OR HE DOES NOT
REMEMBER.
IN EITHER CASE, THIS TIME FROM
THE 20.
AMENDMENT.
AND YOU'D KNOW WHO HAS TO GET
INVOLVED IN THE 25th
AMENDMENT?
THE VICE PRESIDENT, KAMALA
HARRIS.
BUT THE PROBLEM REALLY IS THAT
HE IS ON THE WORLD STAGE.
HE IS IN A NATION THAT IS
LITERALLY NEXT DOOR TO A COUNTRY
WHERE THERE IS FIGHTING AND WE
ARE ON THE VERGE OF ZELENSKYY
SAYING WORLD WAR III.
WHEN HE SAYS THIS MAN CANNOT
REMAIN IN POWER, THEY HAVE TO
HAVE A PHONE CALL, THE INVESTOR.
NATO HAS TO PULL IT BACK.
THESE ARE DANGEROUS, DANGEROUS
TIMES AND THE RUSSIANS, THEIR
ECONOMY IS SHOT.
THEY ARE LOSING PEOPLE.
THEIR REAL -- ROUPHAEL --
>> IT IS SHOWING -- DOING WELL
AGAINST THE EURO.
I READ AN ARTICLE.
YEAH, THAT IS WHEN --
>> REMEMBER WHEN CUOMO WAS
GETTING ANTSY AND WAS LIKE, HEY,
I'M ITALIAN.
>> YOU AND I BOTH LOVE -- HE
BELIEVES THAT OUR WHITE HOUSE
WANTS TO PROLONG THIS WAR TO
LEAD RUSSIA DRIVE BUT ALSO TO
DEFEND THE UKRAINIANS BECAUSE IT
SATISFIES PUBLIC OPINION BUT
WITHOUT COSTING AMERICAN LIVES.
HOWEVER, YOU ARE RISKING
THOUSANDS UKRAINIANS AND
MILLIONS OF HOMELESS JUST TO
LEAD THE COUNTRY DRY.
>> ONE THING I WANTED TO GET TO
THAT QUESTION.
BUT ON THE APPOINTMENT ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT HAVEN'T NOTECARDS,
SOME PEOPLE HAVE THEM.
HE WAS EXPRESSING A MORAL
OUTRAGE.
WHEN YOU EXPRESS A MORAL
OUTRAGE, YOU DON'T NEED NOTES.
THAT COMES FROM THE HARD.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT YOU CAN
CLAIM THAT A PRESIDENT OF THEY
ARE STATES ON THE WORLD STAGE AT
A SPEECH THAT THEY BILL AS THE
MOST IMPORTANT SPEECH SO FAR, IS
DONE IN HIS PERSONAL CAPACITY.
THAT IS NOT BELIEVABLE TO ME.
BUT THAT IS WHY THE EUROPEAN
LEADERS HAD TO HAVE THIS
MEETING.
TO NEIL'S POINT TO -- I THINK
THAT WHAT HE IS TALKING ABOUT
MIGHT BE THE PRACTICAL RESULT.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS THE
INTENTION OR THE STRATEGY
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME IF HE
WANTED TO LEAD RUSSIA DRY, SHE
WOULD HAVE TO START WITH THAT
SANCTIONS AND POSSIBLY DETERRING
THIS WHOLE SITUATION IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
NOW YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
YOU HAVE MULTIPLE CITIES
DESTROYED.
YOU HAVE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE DISPLACED.
IF YOU HAVE A RUSSIAN ECONOMY
THAT IS GOING TO BE IN DIRE
STRAITS EVEN IF THE RUBLE --
COME BACK.
THEY ARE IN A TERRIBLE
SITUATION.
THE ONE THING I THINK BIDEN DOES
NOT WANT TO DO IS FOR THIS TO
CONTINUE BECAUSE OF THE RISK OF
THIS CALCULATION --
MR. COLLATION.
LEADING TO THE RESENTMENT OF THE
GERMANS AND WORLD WAR II.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE HOPEFUL
THAT THESE TALKS ARE AT LEAST
ONGOING.
>> Piers: CAN I ASK ONE
DIFFICULT QUESTION?
AT WHAT POINT IS THE RED LINE
AROUND MORALITY?
AT WHAT POINT DO WE WATCH
HOSPITALS BEING BOMBED, REFUGEES
BEING TARGETED AND MURDERED ON
THE WAY OUT.
AMERICANS IN LINES OF BREAD
BECAUSE THEY ARE STARVING
CUPPING GOD DOWN.
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS BEING
INCINERATED.
WHAT IS OUR REDLINE.
WE KNOW WHAT HITLER'S WAS.
I LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING ON.
I KEEP READING THAT PUTIN IS
LOSING THIS IS ALL GOING BADLY.
I DON'T BELIEVE ANY OF THAT.
I THINK PUTIN IS DOING EXACTLY
WHAT HE SAID UP TO DO.
HE IS RUTHLESS.
HE IS GETTING MORE RUTHLESS,
MORE BARBARIC.
AND HIDING BEHIND HE HAS NOT
ATTACKED A NATO COUNTRY.
I BET IF HE ATTACKS A NATO
COUNTRY, AND WHAT IS HE GOING TO
SAY?
HE IS GOING TO SAY, IF YOU COME
AFTER ME, I'M GOING TO USE MY
NEW EXPECT WE HAVE THE QUANDARY
OF A GUIDE TAKING NEUTRAL --
GUIDE TAKING NUCLEAR ARMAMENT.
I ASKED THE QUESTION BECAUSE AT
SOME POINT, WE WILL HAVE TO
STAND UP TO HIM.
OTHERWISE, WHERE DOES IT STOP?
I'M JUST THROWING IT OUT THERE.
>> Greg: THERE